Aspetta aspetta Ronaldo trappola
per poco l'ho bloccata trasformazione in
ragno paurosa oggi un nuovissimo gioco
in cui una volta a testa insomma ogni
tanto ci Trasformeremo il ragno paurose
che dovremo mangiare gli altri giocatori
è tipo quel gioco in cui si
trasformavano
in piedi 100 piedi Questo è il gioco del
ragno e lasciate un bel mi piace qua
sotto zero lasciate Mi piace un ragno
gigante arriverà in camera vostra
stanotte
quindi lasciate un bel mi piace qua
sotto Ed eccoci qua iniziamo a chi fanno
paure i ragni a me fanno un sacco di
paura Vitale invece non fanno paura
infatti ogni volta che c'è un ragno in
casa dico Prendilo ma non uccidono
poverino prendilo e accompagnalo fuori
nel terrazzo nel giardino così può
continuare la sua vita da ragno Hahaha
allora nuovi outfit io ho comprato un
vestitino rosa e delle orecchie Rosa mi
piace il mio nuovo outfit
tipo ho perso un giocattolo dietro di
noi non lo trovate un ragno invece
l'outfit di Vitale c'è sempre il cibo in
testa Ovviamente sempre
al pistacchio e poi c'ho dei biscotti
con le mandorle e i panzerotti i
panzerotti e marcia eh eh panzerotti
dolci Eh sì Questo è il 12. Vabbè
comunque non perdiamo altro tempo
entriamo nella casa infestata del ragno
maledetto c'è il ragno non si nasconde
da qualche parte ho trovato qualcosa Ah
che cos'è
l'hai rubato tu Sì dovresti prenderò io
vado attaccati questo no non posso
colpire Vitale cosa c'è altro qui una
porta ho trovato una porta esce
veramente cosa farti prendere del ragno
Prego Prego
si apre niente come funziona
quindi questa è un'escape Room perché
dobbiamo risolvere un mistero in questa
casa e riuscire a scappare dalla casa
senza essere mangiati dal Ragno e io ho
trovato una chiave verde e ho lasciato
il cosino per distruggere il ragno
quindi prendilo lo spray per gli insetti
Ah guarda allora funziona benissimo
contro il ragno Ok tienilo Casomai
incrociamo il ragno spruzzagli addosso
va bene Aiuto dove stiamo andando Non lo
so dobbiamo esplorare la piano piano di
sopra io ho una chiave verde vedi
Dobbiamo trovare una porta con una
chiave verde va bene e poi non so cos'è
Qui c'è una porta Marrone
che c'è Hai trovato qualcosa cioè quando
c'è scritto però eh C'è una foto
Ah praticamente aspetta aspetta
nero e oscuro non si riesce a capire
cos'è forse è una foto del ragno gigante
oppure è un fantasma c'è una chiave
inglese qui Prendila Ehi è passato il
coso per per gli utenti
Mi è scappato un dito Qui c'è un
passaggio segreto dove qui Ok proviamo
Ehi ma no siamo tornati in salotto Ah
una via di fuga hai capito sopra perché
ho visto uno scantinato sopra
Guarda qua ci sono delle scale per una
soffitta no c'è scritto che si sbagliano
chi chi è che si sbaglia c'è una chiave
rossa ci sono degli articoli di giornale
vediamo cosa c'è scritto
ha fatto fuori sua moglie ma cioè loro
dicono che si sbagliano perché forse
vuol dire che è stato il ragno e hanno
incolpato una persona in realtà ma è già
ferragno
un uomo è impazzito ok No non sanno che
in realtà c'è il ragno che sta compiendo
questi delitti il ragno che li sta
facendo impazzire Sì aspetta Faccio così
guarda cioè ho preso una chiave rossa
Aspetta tu prendi la chiave verde qua
qua guarda salta salta
salta però la perdiamoci se ticida è più
importante la chiave e adesso come
faccio una ragnatela vuol dire che il
ragno è passato quasi sicuramente
vediamo se c'è qualcuno là fuori Ho
ripreso la chiave verde Cosa c'è qui
Guarda
capannone bunker gli altri giocatori
hanno aperto la porta ecco qui ho
trovato una cassaforte e con una chiave
gialla
c'è una barchetta e sono riuscita a
scappare anche tu
Mentre aspettiamo la prossima partita
abbiamo notato che abbiamo trovato
alcuni di voi fanno Guardate nella chat
sono la vostra fan vi amo vi amo
Ciao grazie Vi salutiamo Allora sono
Raffy Ciao Rock ciao ciao ciao Mavi e
lam7 Zin è un po' difficile da leggere e
poi anytse la mia vita immagino un
personaggio di mercoledì Ciao a tutti
Ciao bellissimo incontrarvi nei giochi
non so come fate a trovarci ma comunque
è bellissimo e ora nuova partita Ok
nuova partita comunque non c'era mai
successo cioè non mi era mai successo
che nella prima partita riesco a
scappare a vincere grazie ad altri
giocatori in genere muore muore muro
muro Ah adoro in continuazione finché
non riesco a vincere Questa volta non mi
lasciare solo io già sono scappato dove
sei oh aiuto Aiuto Sta andando a
prendere le chiavi la prima cosa che
dobbiamo prendere per provare ad aprire
la porta fuori ok ok comunque Che strano
ancora non abbiamo visto il ragno e
qualcuno ha aperto già una porta là
fuori vedete una è verde e uno è rossa
non le avevo viste quelle porte Okay
andiamo però da qualcuno non ha eh cioè
ho preso già le chiavi Io ho bisogno
delle chiavi ho visto che c'era una
chiave nella cassaforte Seguimi ok Dove
sei sotto Ok vai Prendi la chiave subito
dopo avermi il ragno per una casa
fortuna non mi ricordo più aspetta
aspetta qui c'è una chiave blu Prendila
Okay presa chiave Blu Ok ok possiamo
uscire fuori fuoco
la chiave nella cassaforte e se mi dici
dov'è Allora guarda qui No abbiamo
chiuso per rompere Sì E dove sarà oggi
da qualche parte Ehi qualcuno è una
batteria in mano una batteria gigante a
cosa servirà questo allora io l'ho visto
quello era in cucina il piede di porco
Ok vieni vediamo al piano di sotto gli
dico Beh oh aspetta
anche tu fa questa casa è un po' strana
Ok sono il pieno di sotto ok Dove Ah
eccoti ti vedo vieni Seguimi Allora
avevo visto il piede di porco qui guarda
Eccolo lo vedi Ok allora lo prendo e
andiamo ad aprire quella porta andiamo 3
minuti come 3 minuti così veloce dai dai
dai dai dai dai sbrighiamoci
ancora è non è arrivato il ragno usa qui
il piede di porco
Dio
vai ok apriamolo entra adesso devi solo
Aprire una cassaforte con la chiave con
la chiave arancione
brava Non ce l'ho la chiamerò azzurro
dove va Quella blu adesso dobbiamo
capire fuori Ok Allora ehm oh Guarda ho
trovato un passaggio segreto Ah no porta
solo qui io provo a uscire fuori vediamo
che cosa hanno fatto con altri giocatori
nel frattempo Aspettami Però allora sto
venendo qua fuori No aspetta ho
sbagliato porta devo uscire dall'altra
parte Ecco perché non trovavi L'uscita
prima che
Oh è un giocatore trasformato in ragno
lo vedete è bruttissimo Qui dove si va
qui Vieni Guarda ho trovato un passaggio
segreto Corri corri Qualcuno ha chiuso
il ragno da dentro comunque Eccoci qua
Ehi dove ti sei buttato qua sotto Wow
wow
c'è una chiave che io c'ho la chiave blu
Io c'ho la chiave gialla eh A cosa
servirà
la chiave gialla o arancione Controlla
bene perché forse era quella che ti
serviva No questa è gialla Allora
dobbiamo è caduto qualcuno è caduto e no
vuol dire che il ragno tramandato molto
doveva utilizzata la chiave blu non
capisco Non lo so devo cercare qualcosa
per la chiave Ah che è successo
se funziona qua la chiave no qua ci
vuole la chiave viola
per uscire Vero
Ah oddio attento il ragno proprio lì
chiave gialla chiave gialla facciamo
vedere Forse dobbiamo Ascolta Mi è
venuta un'idea forse le chiavi sono
nascoste lì dove c'è dove c'è il ragno
Prova a spaventare il ragno Io entro Oh
Questa c'ha una chiave Viola tu oh oh
Vediamo se come dici tu c'è qualcosa
qualcosa no
Oh attento sta arrivando davanti
trappola verde
no no no no Anita scappo sempre
zitto Sei tu che mi hai detto di entrare
là dentro portava portarci subito
arancione eccomi finalmente entra lì
dove c'è la cacca Sono stata mangiata
adesso Vediamo facciamo da spettatrice
Vitale che è immobile lì non fa niente
qui lo vedi
Sì Attento a non farti mangiare Allora
qualcuno cercava la batteria che è lì la
batteria è davvero io là dentro dove c'è
la trappola al bagno sì e la tomba della
moglie che ha incolpato il marito ma in
realtà è stato il ragno ora che non c'è
più la ragnatela perché mi sono
sacrificata io potresti provare ho
trovato la batteria la richiesta la
batteria qui per aprire ah ah ah Ah ho
trovato ho trovato ho trovato la chiave
la chiave che mi serve per per aprire la
cassaforte
ti conviene sbrigarci Apri questo apri
apri apri Apriti sesamo che cosa lo
spray per per gli insetti spruzzarglielo
il ragno così no
avete perso dovevate sbrigarvi Eccoci
qua cosa sta succedendo stiamo
sperimentando Siamo a un tavolo il ragno
Eccolo ma è piccolino adesso eh È
piccolo Uh cattivo
gusto
tutti tutti omaggio a me non ci credo ti
ha morso e ora ti stai trasformando
Oh radio gigante che abitavo sei un
bravo ragazzo Anita Stories Sono
orgoglioso di essere tuo zio ok Sì ma
sono una femmina e perché faccia così
tutte storte ora Passami un altro po' di
questo eh passami altri morendo di fame
ma come chi sei Che cosa c'entra con il
ragno che cosa sta succedendo Non lo so
Sto facendo un campeggio quindi oddio
oddio guarda le mie braccia cos'era quel
rumore probabilmente non era niente ma
dovrei andare a controllare Torno subito
con le braccia rotte
Cosa posso fare non posso neanche
difendermi in macchina
correre
il ragno ha mangiato lo zio
tutto sto quindi stiamo scappando una
baita Forse posso trovare aiuto lì
dentro sono io il ragno Non ci posso
credere
heheheh aiuto
se ti azzardi a mangiarmi mi vendicherò
Ok prendo una chiave inglese non so cosa
servirà Ma credo di aver visto qualcosa
fuori c'è qualcuno qui
Non ti azzardare a guardare dove sono
poi Stories Family controllate che
Vitale non guardi il mio schermo per
vedere dove fanno venire a mangiarmi eh
8 trappole posso mettere 8 posso mettere
le trappole Eh quello in cui sono caduta
prima ne mettiamo una qui Uffa ma qua
manca tutto interessante dobbiamo
sbrigarci Dobbiamo trovare tutto
Mamma mia sei bruttissimo amore Guardate
Figo No vabbè Mi sto divertendo troppo
quello che bello gioca la scatola C'ha
pure il cappello in testa quel cibo
Ehi tu sei l'unica che può aiutarmi
siamo solo in tre Dimmi cosa dobbiamo
fare Uh che figo posso salire anche qua
sopra
hai messo una trappola qua ma credo che
siamo così scemi Dai cascarci che bello
Così poi potresti cadere spiaccicarsi
dici che posso cadere
Uffa Sono appena caduto dal tetto e non
ti sei fatto niente e No sono un ragno
Peccato ecco finalmente una chiave
chiave rossa
rossa ma vediamo qua c'è il gabinetto è
rimasto bloccato
e sono rimasto bloccato qui
E allora vinceremo noi a zio ragno
devo dire che sei proprio brutto con
tutta questa roba che sono bloccato
Guarda
allontanati ti conviene
sono riuscito a passare dall'altra parte
che cosa ci fa parte per arrivare
vai pure là dentro corri corri corri
Che figo posso passare da una zona
all'altra così velocemente
questa chiave gialla posso dire che
questo gioco mi piace troppo
ti piace tanto perché sei il cattivo
adesso quindi io posso salire sui vari
utensili sulle varie sul camino solo
adesso ad esempio ho trovato qualcuno ho
trovato
qualcuno
ma perché adesso sto rallentando così
tanto come ragno non posso correre Forse
perché non stai mangiando e se non mangi
diventi più lento ci sono un paio di
giocatori qui chiave blu Uffa Ma dove
sono i lucchetti dove devo andare Ah chi
c'è aiuto che cosa c'è niente Ah quindi
eri tu qui dov'è la scala la scala Ma
uffa dove devo andare Dov'è lucchetto
blu chi ci sarà qua niente Cioè nessuno
cioè non c'è un cavolo Oh no Poverino io
non ho fatto niente Meno male si è
liberato un personaggio era nel caduto
Nella tua trappola Davvero Sì ma ormai
si è liberato quindi Peggio per te
devo mettere l'altra trappole allora
chi potrò prendere lasciamo una trappola
Qui sulle scale ah
Ah ah ah aiuto
Aiuto
No sono magari lui è l'unico che sta
cosa deve fare questo gioco Ah ah ah ah
ho mangiato Poverino
Oh poverino smettere è caduto Uffa Ma
dove devo andare aprire arancione qui ho
trovato una chiave arancione Però io
sono io il ragno quindi devo vincere io
chiave gialla e chiave verde diciamo chi
c'è altro qui forse con la chiave verde
poteva aprire qualcosa
Ahia c'è un bel popolo mancava aiuto
ragno Vitale aveva capito
dove siete Vi faccio una trappola mi sa
Sì sì mi nascondo qui e appena qualcuno
arriva me lo mangio per il bunker chiave
arancione Sì ma come faccio
arancione e chi è questo vediamo C'è
qualcuno
ho preferito Ok Esatto ora voglio essere
io il radioti sfracellerò Ok facciamo da
spettatori finché non sarò io il ragno
nuovamente
Non ti azzardare a guardare il mio
Scherzo
dai fate qualcosa anche loro non sanno
cosa fare Non si capisce dove sono tutti
i lucchetti Adesso vedo se c'è qualcuno
qua fuori Magari metto anche delle
trappole lì in quella stanza Eccolo
Vitale ragno sta per prendere qualcuno
in trappola Oh no scappa ma perché mi si
è nascosto qui questa come ha fatto a
nascondersi Com'è possibile che non lo
prendi
Però possiamo prendere questa Oh no
scappa veloce scappa e c'è beccato poco
ma non riesce a muoverti bene eh hehehe
sono un po' lento Ecco la poverina ah ah
non l'hai presa non ce l'hai fatta ne
sono a casa nelle tue trappole non è
giusto però vado per mangiare un
giocatore Guarda questa che sta qui
guardala nascosto
si era nascosta bene però devo dire
anche gli altri giocatori sono nascosti
in due minuti ce la farai vediamo sono
tutte e due qua
Ok allora
e poi vediamo Magari mettiamo anche una
trappola qui
Oh no così non possono più entrare
dentro casa
[Musica]
sono un ragno malvagio del quale parte
entrerà
Adesso vuole scappare da qui immagino e
Io metterò una trappola
No è riuscito a prenderlo Mi è scappato
credo che non riesco
è riuscita a scappare adesso questa non
mi scappa però la prenderò
No
sei un po' schiappa come ragno Qualcuno
si sta andando a nascondere qui Vediamo
se riuscirò a prenderli ma non sono
molto nascosti Ehi ma perché non li fa
prendere se sono lì c'è un bug Ehi basta
però vi state facendo stancare Uh questo
lo prendo lo prendo lo prendo lo prendo
lo prendo Ah ah ah ah ha preso Quindi
solo uno per una risposta un personaggio
da come sono stato stordito
no
stavano aspettando apposta il tempo Sì
così
piccolo
Ben ti sta ragnaccio
prossima partita vediamo chi sarà il
ragno adesso
[Musica]
di nuovo da me sta venendo No no sta
controllando tutti prima di decidere
vedi
ha preso quella giocatrice Quindi io e
te dobbiamo scappare capito dai dobbiamo
scappare da radio però questa volta
Cerchiamo di
non so che cosa serve la chiave inglese
Allora vediamo qui ce ne serve la chiave
blu OK chiave blu apre quella porta poi
questo vai subito ad aprire quel pezzo
dov'era e poi qua ecco abbiamo bisogno
della scala certo ok qua che cosa
richiede la chiave arancione
credo di aver visto qualcosa là fuori
quindi vuol dire che è arrivato e sta
per entrare qua dentro aiuto chiave
rossa Hai visto dove serve la chiave
rossa
vediamo forse qua ecco la chiave rossa
qua qua
dove serve la chiave rossa
[Musica]
gialla
Non mi dire che ti ha preso anche a te
subito
Te l'ho detto questo radio è
difficilissimo per favore spaventato
è troppo forte questo ragno
vedi un cane perché è un cane
Ecco si nascondono qua perché così non
riescono ad essere preti Siamo stati
proprio schiappe in questa partita
troppo facile per lui dico e così di
nuovo qua intorno al tavolo Siamo in
quattro questa volta Vediamo Chi
sceglierà
il robot
tanto tanto tanto tanto tanto
e adesso perché andrà No è andata da
questo giocatore Pensavo fossi io il
radio visto che ho raddoppiato le chance
Ma niente allora sbrighiamoci facciamo
un gioco di squadra Io Innanzitutto Qual
è la prima chiave da prendere Allora
facciamo un giro andiamo subito a
scoprire che cosa possiamo fare chiave
blu e o la scala Allora io qui ho
trovato questo perfetto posso rompere
questa cosa qui dai pronto Adesso io la
chiave rossa sai cosa usare rossa Ah
brava questa ragazza ha aperto qui che
cosa ha preso la chiave Questa è la
chiave arancione ha preso il DDT la
ragazza Ok che sarebbe
lo spruzzino per per il ragno
Che brutto il ragno bruttissimo è zombie
ma perché devo devo essere sempre in
grande è stato stordito Dai dai dai
muoviamoci adesso deve sempre inseguire
meno okay okay okay allora Okay ho
aperto quella porta ora c'è la chiave
blu la chiave blu mi serve Ok chiave blu
pressa che abbiamo di sopra
via via via via aiuto aiuto aiuto si sta
prendendo l'albero brutto il ragno
Zombie bruttissimo ok ok ok ok ok Dove
sei andato Eh non lo so mi sembra il
giro anzi il ragno il ragno Wow ragno
sano ha preso qualcuno il ragno di già
Ah da che parte passiamo Non lo so
chiave verde chiave verde chiave verde
Eh no io che cosa serve Ah qualcuno è
caduto ok e da qua saliamo al piano di
sopra che cosa succede Ah la scala la
scala per il piano di sopra qui c'è la
scala prendi la vita dove non lo so dove
sei tu io sono il piano di sopra e
potevi portare la scala Giacché Hehehe
zitto Zitto
non mi ha preso mamma mia Eccola qua
devo mettere la scatola Allora vicino
alla tomba là fuori cioè quella scala lì
eh devi andare lì vicino alla tomba Ok
Io sto salendo ad aprire questa questa
porta blu Ok vado a prendere la scala no
all'uscita ho sbagliato e dall'altra
parte
Ah perché dovevo mangiare meno qualcun
altro Allora io ho aperto la porta qui E
questa mi ha preso quelle cose per
aprire Aiuto Aiuto dove sei e sto
scappando dal Ragno Vabbè la prendo io
la scala
Ecco sto andando là fuori dalla tomba
l'hai presa
allora prendo la chiave blu che ho visto
che l'ho sempre usato la chiave blu Ah
ah ah Stai attenta Ti aiuto poi c'è il
ragno Zombie coi in testa il cappello
della laurea Papi proprio perché sei
così schiattarà Ehi guarda che non mi ha
mangiato ancora
Ok ho messo la scala Ok Saliamo in cosa
si è laureato il ragno Secondo te non lo
so che cosa c'è Hahaha Ma qui c'è una
via d'uscita per scappare sì che cosa
c'era niente
fallo Non serve proprio un bel like c'è
una batteria qua prendi la batteria
Bravo andiamo fuori la batteria serve
fuori Mi sta venendo l'albero
quello che vuoi perdere per aprire lì
Prendilo Prendilo prendilo prendi la
chiave verde No io non ce l'ho la chiave
bella Te l'ho detto che per aprire e lo
so trovo io l'ho trovata io ero in bagno
con la chiave gialla stiamo facendo un
lavoro di Squadra Femminile Sì dai Forse
questa volta ce la caviamo quotidiana
Allora ho preso lo spray per insetti
così grande difendere qualcuno Vieni
vieni fuori ok aspettate c'è il bagno
Qui c'è il ragno qui attenta Attenta
allora aspetto che entri e poi gli spray
spruzza Bravissimo
Io vado subito ad aprire la porta Vai in
bagno stiamo laureato Ah guarda guarda
la batteria Allora vieni vieni giù Vieni
giù Sì sì Sono quaggiù il bagno sono
Eccoti Ecco
dobbiamo stare attenti
ma lo spray funzionerà un'altra volta
Eccoti Ok ok e qui il ragno lo vedi
funziona funziona proprio no no no non
mi dire che ti ha preso Non mi dire che
ti ha preso Aspetta aspetta
Aiuto Una cosa dovevi fare spruzzare il
bagno
[Musica]
guarda sono riuscito ad attivare questo
Quindi ci manca solo di aprire le barre
di legno bravissimo
Hahaha
Che paura ti va a casa la chiave Bianca
c'ero quasi mancava così foto sdoppiato
di cibo in testa ad aver attirato
Giusto Ora speriamo che gli altri
giocatori riescono a scappare in qualche
modo No non li prende lì per quello ci
nascondiamo tutti lì e sono riuscito ad
aprire l'altra porta con la batteria
attivando tutto però è andata a trovare
quella chiave Viola dai che è facile No
perché sono in ostaggio del ragno vedi è
lì è lì che non li vuole far muovere
andava lì al momento giusto a spruzzarlo
Guarda che lo spray tu mi hai detto che
funzionava sempre invece si doveva
ricaricare per colpa tua hai mangiato il
ragno spruzzo non ce l'avevi tu mica io
dovevi controllare questa cosa
ok questa giocatrice sta scappando
facilissima Speriamo che prenda la
chiave Viola manca solo una cosa per
loro per poter scappare manca solo la
chiave Viola che abbiamo fatto un bel
lavoro di squadra adesso dai Trovo la
chiave Viola dai sbrigati mancano 3
minuti e 27 dai Contiamo su di te stepsi
e poi che altro c'è no no no no no no no
devi scappare più veloce no mi sa che lo
prenderà Lollo sta girando intorno no no
no
E poi c'è la donna Oh qualcuno è andato
con lo spray spruzzato bene mamma Arrivo
arrivo
bloccato
no deve prendere la chiave Viola c'è di
sotto Brava Scendi dai sta che tutto
bene Dai manca pochissimo per scappare
dai trovate questa chiave Viola abbiamo
fatto un sacco di lavoro che che è
successo
prima lei è riuscita a spruzzarlo ma
non prendono la chiave Viola non capisco
perché non la prendo adesso qua sotto ci
vuole la chiavetta
l'ho trovata
Ora ci riescono
Sì si sta aprendo la porta bravi Sì sì
Loro sono scappati ora e adesso dobbiamo
scappare anche gli altri sì questa
giocatrice
No è rotto non rotta
rotolina
Uffa non ha capito che la porta è aperta
perché non il cazzo Dovrebbe esserci un
anno aperto le porte Guarda guarda
dall'altra parte deve scappare No non da
lì Oh no 46 secondi Dai sbrigati ce la
puoi farcela dall'altra parte devi
uscire non da qui ho sbagliato uscita Mi
sa che non ce la farà a scappare questa
giocatrice mi sa che è la prima volta
che gioca sta arrivando il ragno Guarda
che sta arrivando il ragno sta arrivando
il ragno scappa Oh no cinque cascate del
tempo almeno due giocatori tre giocatori
si sono salvati
Allora vediamo se questa volta solo io
ragno io voglio essere radio questa foto
perché devo per Vitale vendicarsi che
lui abbia mangiato Chissà Vediamo chi
sono io ah ah ah ho preso un
altro uovo
io voglio essere ragno Ok nuova partita
questa volta ce la farà Anita Stories è
vitale questa volta a scappare senza
essere sfracellati da ragno qui serve la
scala Qui c'è la chiave inglese che non
mi ricordo che cosa serve la chiave
inglese anch'io non mi ricordo dove sono
tutte le chiavi o forse ogni volta
cambiano Eh sì certo cambiano posto Ah
ecco perché non mi ricordo mai dove sono
dobbiamo aver visto qualcuno là fuori
è arrivato
ha aperto questa porta la chiave blu non
serve perché la zona aperta
quando
che cosa è successo lì dentro casa
attento eh Ok ciao ciao
che cosa c'hai tu come oggetto niente
come niente Allora qua c'è una chiave
arancione e una chiave verde cosa serve
non lo so dovrebbe mettere niente
Vedo se serve qua con l'arancione per il
DDT per lo spruzzino E dov'è È lo
spruzzino nella cassaforte di sopra Ok
vado a prenderlo allora
Mmm se riesco a scappare dal Ragno
No mi hai intrappolato
Sì è anche messo delle trappole la
chiave blu la chiave blu già non mi
serve più no no no
ho messo due trappole nelle porte così
via non posso entrare
aiuto piano di sopra ma io non cadrò
Nella tua trappola possiamo anche fare
il giro giro tondo
tanto non mi prenderà altro Allora vieni
C'è la chiave arancione io non posso
entrare a me sembra trappole Ma dove
dove non puoi entrare Se sei qui Oh dove
sei
Amore ho messo due trappole vero
Ha messo anche una trappola qua non ci
credo ha detto bloccherò anche la mia
entrata qua allora aspetta vengo ad
aiutarti io
penso di aver capito come fare no non
uscire perché sono cadrai in una delle
trappole penso di aver capito come fare
[Musica]
aiuto Attento No non farti prendere non
cadere nella trappola
mi ha proprio intrappolato questo
l'audio Sto cercando di venire a
liberarmi Sì aiuto
Adesso proviamo eh
con l'arco con questa posso utilizzarla
vediamo aiuto prima o poi mi prenderà lo
posso continuare a scappare all'infinito
se io rimango intrappolato per quanti
secondi Oh sta arrivando Qui sta
arrivando qui però non è riuscito ad
aprire e qualcuna è caduta nella
trappola Ok una trappola una trappola si
è scomparsa almeno ok è scomparsa
capiamo Finalmente sono riuscita a
tornare sopra Allora la cassaforte era
al piano di sopra Sì era pieno di sopra
Ok vado subito a prendere lo spray
Allora qui ci serve la batteria per
poter aprire questo io scappo Ah avete
messo la scatola Bravissimi Non c'è
nessuno che questa parte qua Guardate
dai Sai dov'è Ok qualcuno è rimasto
intrappolato qui e il ragno sta andando
scappa ragazzo scappa
Eh ma sta mettendo un sacco di ragnatele
questo qua eh o no c'è bloccato C'è
bloccato qui Sì è furbissimo quel ragno
stare trappole Qualcuno ha aperto qua
sotto però Ah ah ah ok Ho aperto la
cassaforte e ho preso lo Slime no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no quasi ora vengo io a
salvarvi perché spruzzerò il ragno Io
c'ho la batteria ovunque Dov'è Allora io
sono dentro casa e sto per uscire fuori
Però ho paura che il ragno abbia
piazzato queste Infatti Ecco vai vai vai
vai bravissima Anita adesso Io mi libero
metto la batteria Oh no sei caduto
nell'acqua apposta così posso rialzarmi
Okay attenta qui ci fanno un sacco di
trappole ho messo la batteria Intanto
devo aspettare un minuto prima che si
ricarichi basta basta Mi raccomando Io
intanto ho aperto la porta Io faccio la
tua Bodyguard Ok bravo
E non cadere nelle trappole però no no
no no no no aspetta non sei
[Musica]
Ma che cavolo sempre mi faccia la chiave
viola dove sarà la chiave Viola Grazie
comunque hai capito per avermi aiutato
Ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah
pochi secondi mancavano pochi secondi
non ci credo il ragno questa volta
prossima partita Vediamo se questa volta
finalmente ho Anita Stories sarà un
ragno o no vediamo
qualcun altro
il mio obiettivo in questo gioco sarà
solo mangiare Vitale gli altri non mi
interessano Ma perché Eccomi qua mamma
mia che brutta la radio oh oh oh quattro
gambe e quattro Braccia tutte storte
Allora io vado subito ad esplorare qua
sopra Vediamo che cosa c'è il tuo
obiettivo o cedere
ragnatele per intrappolare i giocatori
questi percorsi Viola sono visibili solo
a te USA Eli per scalare le pareti Eh ma
insomma posso andare Ecco
questa bruttissima
però devo dire che sono un po' lenta
come ragno Dove siete uscite fuori siete
il mio pranzo e cena e colazione pronti
a essere mangiati dai Ecco qualcuno
ho visto qualcuno qua
c'è nessuno ok Non siete d'accordo tutti
tanto vi mangerò vi troverò vi manderò
Qualcuno dovrà prendere le chiavi qua
quindi mettiamo una trappola
Ehi sbaglio sbaglio
l'odore di forza 0
dove c'è Vitale c'è una scia di cibo
quindi di odore di cibo quindi ti
troverò Vitale e ti mangerò Ho un'idea
proviamo a mettere una trappola qua
che hai preso sei riuscito a prendere
qualcuno ma non riesco a prenderlo Ma
insomma
È inutile Allora questa trappola
poi dovrai troppo forte vabbè andiamo a
cercare Ehi
io voglio stare qua eh Dove due
giocatori dai devo mangiare almeno
uno ancora non ho mangiato nessuno ha
un'idea Adesso vi metto io delle
trappole
farò la stessa tecnica
no no no no no no no no no no no Non ti
azzardare ci fa scappare Non ci credo
subito con quella bomboletta oh no
adesso devo scappare scappa vita scappa
trappole anche per voi
provate pure ad avvicinarvi Uffa Ma
basta ma perché devono mettere quel muro
lì
qualcuno è entrato qua dentro Sì
finalmente ho preso con qualcuno Anzi
due No solo un giocatore ho preso una
giocatrice finalmente
Ecco Vitale tanto da qua non puoi
passare perché ci sono le trappole
Anzi vengo io a mangiarti
dove sei
vediamo gli altri giocatori dove sono
nel frattempo e ancora lì nascosti E che
cavolo Vitale
il ragno ragno puoi scappare perché ci
sono le trappole non puoi uscire
dove ti sei nascosto adesso ti trovo
pieno di sopra
mi hai spruzzato almeno per ragni Come
ti sei permesso Ora sono ancora più un
ragno arrabbiato Ok io ho liberato
intanto libero questa cosa qui 6 secondi
4 3 sono riuscito a liberare un'uscita
qui vai vai finalmente mi sono ripresa
Ok allora che cosa manca qui ma questo
colore
la notte
Adesso sono ancora le mie trappole
quindi è difficile che riescano ad
entrare Insomma
stiamo a mangiare gli altri giocatori
vedo un piatto di cibo qua
dove credete di scappare Tanto ci sono
le trappole non potete Ehi ma qua c'era
una trappola l'ho tolta io Dai dai è
bloccato quando eri bloccato sono
entrato dentro così ho detto posso
liberarle gli altri Uffa dove siete
bravo questo riuscito a mettere questo
bravo Adesso vi troverò e vi mangerò dai
trova qualcosa trova qualcosa perché
sono così lenta
Eh sì dai vieni vieni vieni vieni che
vuole prendere una mosca
Vieni che sono pronto
Adesso ti metto la traccia no non ci
credono di nuovo
scappare sono più arrabbiata che mai si
mangerò senza pietà e io Adesso tolgo le
altre trappole no
sbrigati sbrigati sbrigati io ho ancora
due trappole Devo trovare il modo di
mangiare Vitale il mio obiettivo non è
mangiare gli altri non mangiar Vitale
Vediamo se questo è riuscito ad aprire
qua sotto Sirio 4 minuti per mangiare
Vitale Vi ricordo che la chiave rossa
era lei no
Oddio vieni che ti spruzzo subito
Adesso vi prego ok almeno ho preso
un'altra giocatrice Che figo sono
riuscito a scappare
ma l'importante è ora è prendere Vitale
Dai vieni Anita Dai vieni qua no non ce
la farei a spruzzarvi no Sei sicura
ah ah
sei perfida va bene
Devo assolutamente prenderlo
Uffa un minuto e 10 ancora avevate
caricarla
carni adesso
Ma dove credi di andare Eccolo
fermo no lasciami in pace dai devo
aprire questa porta che non so dove
porterà minimamente no no no no no no
finalmente l'abbiamo messa è stata
completata
ora mi manca ancora un giocatore forse
anche questo sono perfette finalmente
vincerà il ragno
era l'ultimo quello
ho eliminato tutti Ho vinto ora non ci
credo
finale per questo gioco lasciate un bel
mi piace Ora vi lasciamo qua parte
dell'INPS di cliccare per vedere i
nostri altri video cliccate su quello
che preferite eh Buona visione Ciao